yeah I think that's the end of the no
but you know what I think it's okay I
think if you do it while you have a
boner it's kind of like okay right
everything flies if you have a boner
including eating ass but he they're not
into it
no Dark Lord of suffering mm-hmm I don't
know I don't think it's that simple
I don't think I have this I have this
rule where anything goes in the bedroom
and I'm I don't say no okay let's get
biological okay science with kalila all
right I'm gonna get scientific in
science Amy and let me just see
something I don't know much about the
body right well I have the large
intestine the small intestine right the
processed food back okay and it turns
into poop right it comes out of one hole
the dark hole of suffering
there it is biological biological what
there's no like I don't care what guy a
gay guy said that no there's a g-spot in
the butt hole
yeah there is a prostate no there isn't
yeah literally is yes you can actually
literally I've had my eye on you you
guys are as bad as like Christian I've
had rock-hard poop I've had soft poop
I've had diarrhea right I bet every kind
of thing go through my butthole yeah
yeah I've stuff things in it yeah just
my mental right just listen to me right
there's not a penis or sweet spot right
it's pain and suffering I don't like it
all right
it hurts black all the suffering it
hurts at first yeah it always hurts
yeah there's no g-spot there we go I'm
climaxing [ __ ] you men have one they do
sweetie it's your prostate sits there
yeah what yes and your prostate yes it's
it's there how do you guys don't know
this I feel like you're like have you
lasted your own butt holes yes I have
and you've be a little fingers and I
wonder why you can't get up oh it's good
you gotta go deep you gotta go these
really like et things you need my
fingers or like another person yeah okay
let me just say this that if I bent over
yeah okay and I'll let you stick your
[ __ ] sweaty et finger to my Buffalo
right and you [ __ ] [ __ ] love it
no I'm not listening I will try it but
if I don't orgasm
I'm gonna [ __ ] fight you how much
time do I have to find it there's no
time oh you better find it quick all
right because my butt will clinch up
you're gonna lose that finger okay to be
fair like are you going to you need to
go into it with an open mind like with
you can't go into it it's just off to an
orgasm it's not [ __ ] I think I have
to now in my head believe that it's like
this feels good even though I'm
suffering yeah yeah oh yeah hurts so bad
you have to be open to it
I said I said I'll do it so I'm gonna be
open to it that's maybe like think about
this like we have Clips right yeah and
it feels good when you rub our clits
do you know what if we don't go into it
with an open mind it's not gonna feel
good I know but still look if someone
rapes our quit that's like disgusting
that's a weird thing to rape it
specifically nobody no matter that would
be a weird right
[Music]